bal de la bande dessinée de buts 19e
édition les 13 et 14 octobre nous avons
sur ce plateau trois invités jean marc
le rudulier le maire de buhl bon soir à
vous à vos côtés marc védrines qui est
scénariste et dessinateur et puis
frédéric toublanc dessinateur également
pour marc védrines vous travaillé
notamment sur island ya et la main de
dieu c'est votre actualité on va en
parler et puis pour frédéric toublanc
c'est vasco votre principale actualité
on voit aussi en parlais tout à l'heure
ce rendez-vous festival de buts festival
rendez vous du 9e art soixantaine
d'auteurs en tout sont annoncés vous
avez réussi du côté de l'udc à en faire
un festival véritablement important est
ce que c'était l'objectif au départ non
pas au départ effectivement la première
année on a lancé le festival on l'a
lancée sur une idée de d'un bucquoy de
l'urgent lumière manqué toujours fidèle
et qui est toujours là on n'avait pas
on a lancé on a essayé puis la deuxième
édition puis là et on en est à la 19e
sachant que l'année prochaine on fêtera
les 20 ans de la bd depuis alors qu'il
avait déjà sur l'événement alors laissez
elle s'intéresse à la 19e là les
services travaillent effectivement déjà
sur le sur la 20e et bon pour la
première fois cette année on à l'aide de
la communauté d'agglomération dont nous
faisons partie versailles grand parc
donc qui a bien compris que je pense
qu'il fallait s'intégrer et on le voit
puisque
beaucoup d'écoles debiève de viroflay de
des loges en josas
aujourd'hui et vendredi reçoit des
auteurs et yvon ça va permettre de 2,2
d'indiquer aux enfants que de permettre
aux enfants si vous voulez de te
connaître un peu mieux le festival est
de pouvoir venir au festival en
connaissance de cause festival de but
que ça rendez vous important je me
tourne vers les auteurs qui sont au
plateau oui la bri devait recommencer
justement par jean-luc mirman qui qui
est un habitué de beaucoup de festivals
et qui vient un petit peu a braconné les
auteurs gentiment pour les faire venir
c'est comme ça que vous êtes arrivé
aussi absolument j'étais bras connu par
ci dément il est celui qui est d'aller
braconner ses soixante auteurs qui sont
présents cette année alors ce qui leur à
des hauteurs de france de belgique de
suisse d'italie d'espagne de serbie et
de canada sait comment la bd au canada
c'est très différent de ce qu'on de ce
qui se fait en france
je trouve que c'est à peu près la même
chose je rejoins un voleur qui sont
présents aussi ce qui est une vraie
différence alors l'aider franco belge on
parle en général la bd franco belge mais
la suisse l'italie l'espagne la serbie
c'est très différent de ce qui se fait
en france
jeanine comme il ya une communauté de bd
déjà il ya très peu de pays qui font la
bande dessinée donc on se retrouve
on se comprend je dirais entre nous mais
la france ainsi que la belgique en
europe c'est quand même une exception
culturelle
alors là l'espagne l'italie les pays de
l'est ça reste un petit peu marginale
encore et ce sera à découvrir lors du
festival de la bd à but qui fait la part
belle à la jeunesse cette année on a vu
la fiche c'est gastoon gaston qui a fait
une cure de une cure de jouvence qui a
rajeuni
il est devenu casting pour les plus
jeunes pourquoi mettre mettre l'accent
sur les plus jeunes cette année sur la
bd pourquoi justement bon au début du
lancement du festival jeté par un
connaisseur de la bd et la bd pour moi
c'était tintin et puis astérix est un
bailleur je n'avais lu que ça moi dans
ma jeunesse je me suis aperçu
effectivement que ça changeait beaucoup
et on s'aperçoit qu'effectivement les
enfants sont son sont attirés par la bd
c'est sûr mais beaucoup d'adultes que ce
soit les enfants les adolescents et les
adultes on s'aperçoit qu'il ya un choix
pour toute cette panoplie
néanmoins nous on a voulu insister cette
année sur les enfants pour leur faire
découvrir un petit peu c'est cet art que
ils ne connaissent pas forcément
automatiquement chez eux il y aura des
animations des dédicaces forcément un
moment difficile pour les auteurs les
dédicaces parce que c'est difficile pour
vous parce qu'on patiente pour le public
il patiente pendant des heures on attend
forcément de rencontrer son dessinateur
son auteur et vous comment vous le vivez
c'est difficile parce que c'est bon ça
reste du travail et c'est long mais
c'est un plaisir aussi de rencontrer les
justement le public les personnes qui
nous ont lu et ont fait ça quand même
dans la mesure où on va rencontrer ce
public qui ont dessiné on raconte ses
histoires là pour être en contact avec
ses lifts case farfelues des fois quand
vous le monde descend rares feu lui
c'est des femmes nues fish eye et a eu
l'initiative le vasco précédent
malheureusement pas dans celui là de me
faire dessiner une femme nue donc
effectivement on m'a demandé une femme
nue quelquefois voilà faut faire
attention à ce qu'on décide ensuite ça
vous suit ça vous suit forcément on va
juste faire une petite pause votre héros
de bande dessinée préférée c'est la
question que nous avons posée le maire
de but pour l'entente du ct tintin
astérix
cette année on va voir si les saint
quentinois les évinois partage votre
avis
je dirais série que son parent web par
défaut pourquoi ces risques parce que
c'est celui dont je me souviens mue en
fait c'est une bande dessinée c'est
plutôt dans mon enfance et je sais
vraiment celui dont je me souviens mieux
j'adore les l'histoire toujours avec
oblique ce qu'ils mangent que le
sanglier autour des césar qui perd
toujours ta pas bon c'est tintin
pourquoi tant parce que c'est une
passion mon mari a beaucoup et que je
partage avec lui
voilà c'est un personnage indémodable
c'est boule et bill
franchement ça c'est un des meilleurs
souvenirs que j'ai pu garder des bandes
dessinées ça j'ai beaucoup aimé j'en ai
encore chez moi et franchement c'est
super amusant tout le monde même les
enfants y regarde encore ils lisent et
ça excellent et tout le monde peut dire
quoi donc c'est super c'est super bien
je crois que c'était demandera que
magicien veut y avait un magicien qui
intervenait évidemment avait des tours
chaque fois et qui étaient accompagnés
de d'un noir très musclée alors tous les
deux faisait une peur terrible
les aventures c'est quoi un complètement
disparu c'est dommage d'ailleurs que
c'est pas été repris par d'autres
dessinateurs mende wright boule et bill
on parle du festival de la bd 19e
festival de la bd du côté de but qu'on
va parler de vasco aussi ça c'est votre
ouvrage frédéric milian vasco alors
justement vasco c'est une série
historique ce qui vous passionne c'est
l'histoire le moyen-âge parler d'un
petit peu de ce personnage vasco c'est
un jeune italien
c'est un jeune italien oui du bridage
vous avez dit l'essentiel
il faillait créer ce personnage en 1981
la série a commencé à paraître dans le
journal de tintin et a été une des
meilleures séries du journal de tintin à
sa création
j'ai eu la chance d'être sélectionné
pour reprendre cette série est arrivé
sur le 22ème album 34 dans la dans la
série j'ai fait le numéro 22 et le
numéro 24 est sorti cette année vous
êtes là 12/22 sais c'est difficile
d'arriver en cours de route comme ça
c'est le challenge était de dessiner à
la façon d'un autre dessinateur on se
rend pas compte
spontanément lorsqu'on dessine les
contraintes que ça peut être pour un
autre de
faire de la même façon alors que nous on
le fait spontanément à notre façon et là
il faut se mettre dans le regard dans la
main de quelqu'un d'autre donc le
challenge était là de plus il faut
spécifier que gilles chaillet qui est
donc il a créé cette série en fonction
de ces de ses affinités profondes
c'est un redoutable dessinateur pour les
architectures et amant et là sur le plan
technique c'était c'était assez
difficile
il ya des enjeux difficile en matière de
connaissances d'histoire de l'art en ce
qui concerne l'architecturé le
patrimoine
il s'agit pas de représenter une fenêtre
qu'ils soient pas à sa place
topographiquement est exactement à sa
place il représente un monument reconnu
ce qui complique dès fois le découpage
de mise en scène parce que si le
personnage saute par la fenêtre par
exemple passer par une porte
si la fenêtre ou laporte n'existent pas
hors de question de la dessiner dans le
palais des papes ou à l'alhambra de
grenade
si cette porte ce fait ne figure pas au
cesci attendre les fleurs justement par
exemple ce qui aura des dédicaces
lectures vous y attend son dans la
connivence avec ce qui constitue là le
concept de la série
il s'agit de créer une fantaisie
imaginaire mais sur la base de matériaux
authentiques et le les lecteurs habitués
de la série s'amuse à repérer ces choses
là
alors donc vous serez présent sur ce
festival de la bd on pourra y découvrir
à vasco 24e vous nous avez dire oui il
va intriguer il faut spécifier que la
jaille est alors c'est tout à fait
intentionnellement a créé le personnage
de dames yvelines spécifiquement parce
qu'il avait le festival de musique à je
pense pas que ce soit pour le fils y
aller mais je suis moi-même habitants
des yvelines et je couds cette poussée
pour ça c'est parce que vu que je
mentionnais but parce que vu que c'est
une ville de bd-fil un vieux blake et
mortimer il
qui était ce sos météores qui avait en
partie des sionistes se retrouve on
retrouve d'ailleurs des endroits qui
n'ont pas du tout changé par rapport au
dessin qui ont été faits à l'époque qui
est très liée à la bande dessinée
marc védrines votre actualité vous c'est
la main de dieu c'est le premier tome ce
sera en cinq volets plus sincères dans
un lit sans doute là la main de dieu
vous allez vous intéressez à la saga de
l'homme le plus détesté le plus admiré
des états unis s'est vendu comme ça
c'est john edgar hoover
c'est ce personnage parce qu'en fait mon
hoover j'imagine que dans l'inconscient
collectif tout le monde
c'est ce à quoi il est lié
le fbi a eu même si c'est pas lui qui
l'a créé il faut savoir que ça a été
créé par un neveu de bonaparte un
chargeur de bonaparte en 1908 ça c'est
pour la petite anecdote mais en tout cas
je hoover oms et voilà qu'il a participé
au fbi d'une manière vraiment active
pendant 48 ans en poste
donc c'est assez énorme moi ce qui
m'intéressait à travers ce personnage là
c'était vraiment de montrer qu'il était
vraiment et les coulisses et c'est le
film avec dicaprio qui vous a inspiré
avant dans ça du tout justement s'en
tire pas trop non oui exact donc j'y
suis allé un petit peu penaud en me
demandant ce que ça allait donner ce
qu'on allait raconter la même histoire
avec ce même personnage est en fait non
j'ai été agréablement surpris clint
eastwood traite pas du tout dé même
sujet même si c'est le même personnage
je vous disais ce qui m'intéresse c'est
vraiment les coulisses du pouvoir
comment at il fait pour rester en poste
48 ans des fois ça a été vraiment là qui
est importante tout à fait bien sûr
notamment ailleurs il y en a il faut que
ce soit fidèle faut que ce soit fidèle
sur le plan historique voilà forces
fidèles mais ça a raconté à ma manière
et forcément comme je suis monsieur j
étais pas je le raconte aussi d'une
façon qui peut m'intéresser et le
ferrand le l'écrire pour entreprendre
cette histoire intéressante j'aimerais
vous parler de votre parcours aussi ce
que le temps passe très vite aura
bientôt terminer cette édition vous avez
dessiné votre première bande dessinée à
l'âge de 6 ans oui mais avec un peu
comme beaucoup de dessinateurs qu'elle
estime à 6 ans et ben des cases avec des
petits personnages avec des bulles et on
raconte des histoires en fait c'est
surtout la volonté de raconter des
histoires puis le dessin c'est vraiment
un moyen très facile avec un budget
limité
pour frédéric toublanc vous avez
commencé à quel âge 1re v2 cette bête
dans ce goût là peut-être un peu après
quand même
je crois que c'est neuf ans je crois me
rappeler j'étais en cm1 8 ou 9 ans et
donc vous êtes tombé je la source et en
mettant l'accent sur les plus jeunes
pour cette édition du festival forcément
à un festival qui sera gratuit cette
année ça aussi on n'a pas précisé
l'entrée gratuite oui pourquoi et
comment surtout parce qu'il faut
financer ce festival
drogba le financement il faut dire que
on a on a des sponsors cette année on
allait être comme je vous ai dit qu'à
l'heure de la de la communauté
d'agglomération de versailles grand parc
on est quand même 14 communes les du
conseil général ait beaucoup de
commerçants dont je crois que c'était
pas une entrée
très fort puisque le montant était de
zéro mais je crois que ça ça gênait
quand même si vous voulez on sentait
bien que déjà il faut qu'on paye donc on
attend vous attendez encore plus de
monde cette année je crois combien de
personnes sont attendues le 13 et le 14
octobre
l'objectif étape sur deux mille 2000
personnes et on verra donc le 15 octobre
verra lundi si vous aviez raison si vous
avez réussi à passer cette barre
symbolique des 2000 personnes merci
d'être venus en plateau merci aux deux
auteurs aussi qui était et qui étaient
avec nous une petite précision juste
pour refermer cette édition elle nous
parlions hier du cumul des mandats et de
la colère de l'association anticor qui
lutte pour le retour de la morale en
politique une pétition a été lancée pour
que les députés et sénateurs notamment
socialistes et qui sont mères fasse un
choix comme il s'y était engagé nous
avons aussi évoqué la situation de
benoît hamon ministre et conseiller
régional d'île de france
il nous a confirmé aujourd'hui qu'il
souhaitait conserver ces deux postes et
qu'il était dans la ligne droite est
dictée par françois hollande la charte
de déontologie qu'il a signé en mai
dernier comme tous les membres du
gouvernement demande de ne pas cumuler
un poste de ministre avec un mandat
d'exécutif local comme maire par exemple
ou président de conseil général
il peut donc rester conseiller régional
voilà pour la précision
suite à notre plateau d'hier excellente
soirée le 7-8 revient demain 18h en
direct
n oubliez pas les rediffusions 19h 22h30
et minuit l'actuel aussi le tout images
de la rédaction ça c'est à 20h30 et
notre site internet et les réseaux
sociaux pour commenter nos programmes
bonne soirée